Jewish community leaders in Germany say
they want to see integration classes for
migrants that focus on anti-semitism
saying that this could help stem a rise
in anti-semitic incidents in the country
many of these people have been shaped by
regimes in which anti-semitism is
essential and the Jewish state is denied
the right to live to prevent the worst
scenario we need to tailor the
integration courses to these people much
more preferably by country of origin the
official statistics back up a rise in
anti-semitic crime in Germany just over
400 were reported in the first half of
2018 that's up 10 percent on the same
period last year
the vast majority of these were
committed by neo-nazi and far-right
groups but the leadership of Germany's
foremost Jewish organization paints a
bleak picture of the future saying he
sees more problems coming from migrants
one of the most shocking cases of 2018
was caught on camera showing a 19 year
old Syrian migrant abusing two men from
Berlin for wearing a kippah going as far
as to attack the men with his belt
Jewish leaders have cautioned against
wearing the traditional skullcap so is
not to draw attention in Berlin we've
seen reports of Jewish children becoming
the target of anti-semitic bullying in
school and this summer ten people were
arrested after a brawl in a Berlin park
which started after one group of people
from Syria snatched away a Star of David
necklace worn by a Jewish man also from
the same country over 1 million refugees
and migrants have entered the country
since 2015 and as Chancellor Merkel
points out some have contributed to the
problem we have a new phenomenon as we
have many refugees among whom there are
for example people of Arab origin who
bring another form of anti-semitism into
the country unfortunately anti-semitism
existed before that I met with Berlin
rabbi Yehuda title and asked him how bad
the situation is and if he agrees with
extra integration classes for migrants
focusing on anti-semitism the
problem with anti-semitism in Germany
today is unfortunately growing here is
much worried about the developments in
Germany especially due to the in fact
that many refugees have come from
countries which they were breastfed with
hate towards Israel and towards Jewish
people of course we welcome everybody
but at the same time being a refugee
doesn't only have merits that also has
obligations it's not something that only
affects the Jewish people this affects
all people that honor and respect
democracy I want to live in a society
which respects all people so we have to
understand that this is a very serious
topic gender issue also for the leaders
of the German government and we strongly
encourage them to take it in that manner
this week sees the 80th anniversary of
Kristallnacht or the night of the broken
glass when Jewish homes businesses and
places of worship were set ablaze by
Nazis with the nascent support of Adolf
Hitler's government while the situation
in today's Germany is thankfully a long
way from that of the 1930s that period
of history continues to cast a long
shadow Peter Oliver RT Berlin
you